this is a production of Cornell
University
okay I want to thank Penelope and the
students from the boys Thompson for
inviting me in and this is the first
time I've ever been called a
translational tax anima stand in fact
this is a term translational taxonomy is
a term I coined and so having that term
being actually applied to me is kind of
interesting because no nobody knows what
I'm talking about until I give you no
talk about it and then they're like oh
that's what it is I tend to refer to
myself as a phyto bacteriologist or
sometimes a bacterial taxonomy but a
reluctant one at that but it it is a lot
of what I do in fact or how I approach
research really want to thank thank you
and your cohort for bringing me up here
and I learned a great deal from you all
and I appreciate that just an aside for
mentoring I believe that you know
mentorship goes both ways it really is a
relationship and that mentors often
learn as much from their mentees as the
mentees learn from their mentors and so
that's the approach that I've taken so
I've learned a great deal again here in
fact I learned about app ters app tumors
after Moe's yesterday and so if you
don't know what app to murrs are there
people here that do and I'm going home
to research them because I think they
could be really really powerful okay so
we're going to talk about translational
taxonomy for bacterial pathogens just
two groups of course just to give you an
outline of what we're going to talk
about today really want to talk about
the complicated state of bacterial
taxonomy many people think it's
complicated I don't I can keep lots of
information in different systems in my
head at one time and I like to think
about it so it's not complicated to me
so when people say it's complicated I
think not really however I understand
why people think it's complicated so I
want to explain that I want to give you
some examples of what I mean by
translational taxonomy and I want to
give you a little bit of where I've come
from and where I'm
going in the lab what we're doing right
now so you have a feeling for how you
might be able to collaborate with us for
example and then briefly I just want to
say a few things that we're doing at PSU
in general and I want to do that because
that's where I spend a lot of my time
these days is as a department head and
head of a research center I spend a lot
of time doing other things than the
research so the people who do the
research these are some of the pictures
and you'll see okay so as Penelope said
I spent 20 years in the Salinas Valley
of California working for the USDA some
of the research I'm going to talk about
was done related to the Salinas Valley
and so but much of it is translatable to
Pennsylvania because almost everything
citrus that was grown in the Salinas
Valley and that's other cutters in
citrus are from there but they're grown
in California is also grown in
Pennsylvania so a lot of the same kinds
of questions can be asked in a different
context and in fact I'm still
collaborating across the board on some
of these crops these are the crops that
I worked on when I was working in
Salinas and some of the crop values at
least of 2000 at 2012 the values of
these crops I just note that for example
if we look at cabbage I'll just take an
example the cabbage production in
Pennsylvania is worth three million
dollars instead of thirty five million
and that's that kind of gives you the
the flavor for the whole relationship
between maybe the Salinas Valley in the
salad bowl of the u.s. is what it's
called
versus what we're doing in Pennsylvania
but to the growers that are producing
these crops they're extremely valuable
and so thinking about disease systems
and how to help those growers with their
diseases is important in both places so
what is translational taxonomy so I
think of it just like we think of
translational medicine which is research
basic research that is brought into a
clinic
I think of translational taxonomy in the
same way so it's looking at the three
pillars or the legs of the stool of
taxonomy in order to develop strategies
for disease
which is the seat on which we sit I'm
interested in all three pillars of
taxonomy and relation in relationship to
plant path that bacterial plant
pathogens and I'll just give you a
little bit of what that is like and I'm
gonna give a little bit about bacterial
taxonomy my goal is that you're all
awake at the end of the bacterial
taxonomy part so that we can get into
the disease management part okay so that
is my goal we'll see if it works see if
people are nodding off or not because
often bacterial taxonomy in general
people start to glaze over and yeah it's
something that I do when I need to fall
asleep at night okay so these are some
of my key interests and basic taxonomy
and I just want to put them out there so
that you you know that I am a little bit
nerdy in that I really do find pleasure
in reading about species concepts and
thinking about species concepts for
bacteria in particular in plant
pathogens I'm going to explain a little
bit about the path of our concept and
how we use the path of our concept and
whether or not it fits in some systems
and I'm really interested in where it's
breaking down and why it's breaking down
and I'm also interested in this question
of natural host range versus
experimental host ranges and what that
means for our classification systems and
so I'll just put that out there I
personally want to get rid of the
binomial system of nomenclature and I'll
just say that if you want to talk about
that later it's a it's another hour
seminar but I would like to junk
Linnaeus I think he did a great job of
taking the paragraph that was the name
of of organisms down to two words that
was really helpful but I think now we
need to take it to one and then I I
often talk about identification in with
regard to the appropriate level of
taxonomy where what is your target and
what do you need to at what level do you
need to identify something to actually
control the pathogen and often
researchers we want to get to a more
refined
level then a grower might need or the
grower doesn't know that they need to be
at a more refined level than they are so
so having the appropriate taxonomic
level understood for the management
practices is one of the places where I
go to when I'm talking about
translational taxonomy ok so just a
background about taxonomy in general if
you think about bacterial taxonomy
originally the taxonomy was based on a
very few principles are very few
characteristics and it was really based
on those characteristics that we needed
to distinguish those things that would
kill us from those things that won't
okay or those things that would kill our
plants versus those things that walk so
initially the basis of all taxonomy for
bacteria was really based on a few
principles and they were specific and
you'd see here listed a few of them and
what the result of that was is that the
character the groups that were
classified were not really groups that
potentially were evolutionarily coherent
but they were groups that looked alike
and smelled alike let's say and what
that resulted in were species that were
mono thick that means they had similar
characters and were poly polyphyletic
which means they had different different
evolutionary backgrounds this to us now
seems very unusual because we're used to
trying to put groups into monophyletic
groups and look at their evolutionary
history but if you think about it from a
historical standpoint that's not where
we started and this is really the basis
of where a lot of our our confusion
comes from and I'll just we're going to
talk about Pseudomonas a lot and the
folks who took the workshop heard my
spiel about Pseudomonas yesterday but
pseudo fake monas it's the Greek word
for unit if the word money comes from
the same word okay so it's a fake unit
they put a lot of things in there that
looked alight but they knew
it wasn't really a coherent group and
we've been paying for that ever since
okay okay on top of this subjective era
of classification where we needed it for
health and well-being but on top of that
this idea of the new host new species
cliche that has been written about again
few comparative tests when I isolated
something from broccoli for example I
might not have had at the time the
ability to compare that pathogen to
pathogens from all over the world or
from other hosts in fact and so there
were a few tests that were done
comparatively and there were lots of
different organisms that were isolated
there were actually synonyms for the
same species but which with each new
host people were giving them names and
designating them as species as if there
was a direct relationship between the
host and the specificity of that species
and that isn't necessarily the case or
wasn't necessarily the case but there
was really no way to compare broadly
these organisms this is a second factor
that has really added to the confusion
in Pseudomonas taxonomy okay so this
this led to a number of misconceptions
and a lot of synonyms within the
literature everybody with me so far
okay nobody's sleeping yet I like that
okay so layer on top of that the advance
of our technologies right so we went
from phenotypic testing and maybe host
host range testing into looking at
characteristics that are actually more
amenable to hypothesis testing so if we
talk about nucleic acid based techniques
for classification you can actually
start to do statistics you can do that
even with phenotypic testing but we
begin to think about using numerical
taxonomy or statistical methods for
analyzing these data and now we're at
the point where we can actually look at
whole genomes as well to see whether
these organ
or clonal are they the same are they
different and then how different is of
course the million-dollar question but
as we layer these pieces on top of that
background of confusion if you will or
of subjectiveness it becomes difficult
and it begins becomes difficult to tease
apart what is this the subjective
background and what is the objective
data and I'm going to just show you a
little bit of that as we go forward so
at the same time as we were moving from
the subjective era of classification and
I could spend a lot of time talking
about that era in particular but as we
were moving from that era into a more
objective era there was also going on in
the bacterial community a reorganization
of the code of nomenclature
so remember classification is one part
of the stool but once you've got the
groups classified then you have to name
them and naming is actually done by a
set of rules classification is done
using the scientific method so there's
question inquiry there's data that
support hypothesis but actually naming
the organism has a set of rules there
are no rules for classification per se
or there shouldn't be but for
nomenclature there are and that the
nomenclatural codes are where the rules
are people often confuse that they think
that the classification has some kind of
rules and that there's an appropriate
classification there are best practices
according to the scientific method and
the the thoughts and opinions of the
scientific community but they're not
rules the rules are here in the
nomenclature
okay so the bacteriologists were
reorganizing the nomenclature in fact
they knew that there were synonyms
throughout the bacterial nomenclature
and throughout the species that were
described and this is not just for plant
pathogens it was also for human
pathogens as well so they got together
and developed a new code of nomenclature
and part of the new code of nomenclature
required that there be a catalog of
means for
names of bacteria and that getting into
that catalog required that a name had a
validly published at the epithet and
that means it was published so we could
all read it it had a modern description
so something that we would all be able
to test and distinguish one organism
from another and then there had to be a
nomenclatural type strain that was
deposited somewhere that we could all
get ahold of it and compare our strains
to the problem with this is that it
didn't for plant pathologists the
problem is it didn't include host range
as part of that modern description so
most of our species in fact were based
on this new host new species cliche and
all of a sudden most of our species were
going to go away and disappear in fact
be consolidated and this is the result
of that approved list in 1980 so for
example the Pseudomonas syringes there
were 41 nomen species and most of those
were consolidated into Pseudomonas
syringae okay and the problem with that
is that we still needed to be disabled
to distinguish the pathogen from celery
from the pathogen from tomato and we
could distinguish them based on host
range but not at the level of the
species and that modern description
caused a lot of confusion so what plant
pathologists did and I know some of you
all know this it is that we took the
gnomon species names and these are the
specific epithets for all of these
species and except for those that are in
bold they were all put into Pseudomonas
syringae as path of ours of Pseudomonas
ringing okay those in bold we're all
left as species because they could be
distinguished by modern methods okay so
the path of our concept was put together
as part of the International Science
Society of plant pathologies Committee
on the taxonomy of plant pathogenic
bacteria say that ten times fast and
they developed this idea of a path of
our which is was supposed to be
temporary
so the idea is okay we'll put them all
in Pseudomonas syringae for example and
as we have all of this money for
bacterial taxonomy coming through our
governments we'll be able to tease them
apart into real species again okay you
know there's no money for a taxonomy and
so over over the 40 years that since
this has happened is it 40 years old 80
almost 40 years you know we've had some
progress but it's been piecemeal and
that is really the problem with it is
that we've had a piece of work done here
a piece of work done there and then
trying to understand what that whole
piece means is is what's difficult yeah
we'll go on from there okay so this
concept of path Abbar really a path of
our is designated as something that has
a different host range or causes a
different disease but is within the same
species okay now we don't know whether
or not we didn't at this time know
whether or not these things were
actually the same species or different
species and this has caused a lot of
confusion originally there were paths of
ours for the four species that are
listed here currently we have paths of
ours for over twenty six species just to
give you an idea okay so for plant
pathogenic bacteria now you don't just
have issues with naming bacteria that at
the species level which are coded by the
international code of nomenclature for
prokaryotes seriously if you want to
sleep that's the thing to read but we
also have a code of nomenclature for
naming paths of ours and you have to
work with both of them if you're working
with nomenclature of plant pathogenic
bacteria it's actually the kind of thing
I like to do so I belong on the boards
of both of those groups that do that and
the issue is that we've got species
subspecies paths of ours but often we're
really working at the level of eco types
or strains even when we're talking about
trying to control diseases there can be
differences between one echo type or
cero type or it could be any different
kinds of characteristic that you
waiting there can be differences between
strains at very fine levels and that may
be the level of taxonomy that we need to
be working at and the path of our may
help but it may be at this lower level
that you want to pay attention okay so
just a little more confusion for you so
we've got this group of organisms
they've been put together and now we
have a concept for species that was
layered on top of that so also around
the 1980s there became this idea that
there would be the golden rule for
bacterial species concepts if you will
and this became a species definition and
basically people found that if they did
DNA DNA hybridization and DNA
hybridization values were seventy
percent or above that that they were
likely the same species and just to tell
you what this process is because it's
complicated and not many people used it
you take two different bacteria you
label one of the the DNA from one of the
bacteria usually with a nucleotide of
some sort and that is labeled and you
mix you melt them mix them together and
then you use you let them hybridize use
s1 nuclease to cut away the
single-stranded single-stranded portions
you're left with double-stranded DNA and
then you can measure the radioactivity
in your sample and compare it to a
sample where you've got you've put a the
same organism DNA with the same probe
right so you've got the organism with
itself
if the organism with something else and
the difference between those is the
percent hybridization so for any
experiment where people wanted to look
is this in that species or not they
would have to use all of the controls
necessary and do each of these
hybridizations because you couldn't
create a library of them and just go
online and look so each control had to
be done that means that everybody had to
have those type strains or path of type
strains and people just didn't do it in
fact it it resulted in only a few
laboratories being able to do taxon
at the level that we needed to have
taxonomy done so for a period of about
ten years only a few people in white
towers very esoteric who only wanted to
speak to themselves I'm kidding
don't wait this is being broadcasted
there was a there was a let's see it was
not democratized okay and so it was very
difficult to for have having normal
plant pathologists to be able to
determine the species of an organism
okay fast forward and one of the
problems with this is that if a species
was determine let's say in the case of
Pseudomonas syringae for example it was
determined that all of those paths of
ours actually represented nine different
species but they couldn't distinguish
those species one from another using
phenotypic characteristics and that's a
problem if I can't do the DNA DNA
hybridization in my lab I need those
phenotypic characteristics in order to
be able to look at whether or not
organisms that I'm isolating really are
one species versus another so the
nomenclature would would not allow us to
name species that were really these are
these are species the genomic feces is a
genetic species that we understand to be
related to one another but we weren't
allowed to name them because of the code
of nomenclature because there weren't
characteristics that would distinguish
them in our laboratories so now we've
got a system where we know that there
are nine species but we can't actually
name those species and so Pseudomonas
syringae still had all of these species
they it had nine species in it and and
most people had no idea which was fish
okay so we know that science is
iterative and classification is an
iterative process so when we start out
with the phenotypes and and kind of the
mess that we had in the beginning and
then we start to tease these things out
using the DNA DNA hybridization that
goes on top of that and now we've got
sequence data that we're trying to add
on top of that
we haven't really even cleaned up what
we know about the genotypes yet and so
there's a lot of confusion and where I
think we're going for species concepts
we're gonna get away from sequences
pretty quickly and it's gonna be
function as well as interactions in
conjunction with the sequences that are
going to be the basis of the forthcoming
species concepts okay and if anybody
wants to talk about that that's a whole
nother similar to okay so this is the
current status of Pseudomonas syringae
taxonomy and I just like to present this
to you because this is a clarification
of it okay I'm glad you think so
so I just want to show this to you
because I think I think it helps
formulate this so in gray you have
basically a genomic ease but people have
used sequence analysis to look at the
relationship between these organisms
right and so for example Jeannot most
species 3 which would be Pseudomonas
syringae or Pseudomonas tomatoe if it
was ever proposed to be that but the
type strain would be Pseudomonas during
a path of our tomato DC 3,000 some
people know that here this was
designated as file a group 1 by people
using sequence analysis okay and so some
people will refer to this group as Philo
group 1 some people would refer to it as
Jeannot Jeannot most species 3 Shamoon
Pseudomonas syringae syringe is
Pseudomonas syringae sensu stricto okay
the strictest sense of Pseudomonas ringi
because the type string for Pseudomonas
syringae is in that group and so here
are the different genomic
so for for example Pseudomonas can abena
it's one we're gonna talk a lot about is
a species which many people here some
people here work on organisms in this
group ok but was previously these were
thought to be Pseudomonas ringi but now
people know there are different species
ok everybody with me
anybody reacting like no they're not
sometimes you do the only time I've ever
seen people almost fight like Duke it
out was about this kind of stuff you
can't change the names of things on
people they get really upset okay so
what happens when we get a new pathogen
that it might be a Pseudomonas in the
lab right we test the phenotypic
characteristics to begin with when we've
isolated it and then we go on to do the
the genetic and taxonomic analysis in a
little more detail I'm gonna tell you a
couple of stories now how much time do
we have left
tell me a half an hour okay here we go
I'm gonna tell you a couple of stories
about how we use translational taxonomy
now so in between 2002 and 2010 there
were a number of ice outbreaks of
disease on parsley and these were
fluorescent pseudo monads according to
the phenotypic tests that we
traditionally do okay we knew that there
are two different pathogens that cause
disease on members of the APA see
so there's Pseudomonas during a path of
our coriander Cola which causes disease
on coriander or cumin and there is
Pseudomonas or any path of our API which
causes disease on celery okay and
they've never been reported in fact on
the other crop so we we thought well
maybe the parsley pathogen was one of
these two things okay so the the
approach that we have traditionally used
in my lab as a multiple sequence
analysis now we're moving into a whole
unit genome sequence analysis we can
talk about that later anyway I think you
all know what multiple locus sequence
analysis is you sequence a number of
housekeeping genes you analyze them as
if they were one gene and that gives you
a stronger phylogenetic signal and in
fact we were able to show that the the
these are an IO and you really can't see
this in the translation so these are
different to know most species of
Pseudomonas syringae so these are the
different species we talked about in
that chart
and you can you actually with multi
locus sequence analysis there's really a
good correlation between the mls a
information and the Janome asur the DNA
DNA hybridization values so using multi
liquid sequence analysis you don't need
to use DNA a DNA hybridization and in
fact if you look in the literature
almost all of the plant pathology
literature now will have multi locus
sequence analysis instead of or in
addition to DNA DNA hybridization for
taxonomy okay and it's it's a really
good system depending upon which genes
you use so if we analyze this a little
more closely the the parsley strains
came from both Jeannot most pcs nine or
pseudomonas can abena or from genomic
species 3 which is the tomato group okay
so they were closely related to
Pseudomonas during a path of our api but
in fact the api if you look at the I do
have a pointer don't I I just like to
move okay I didn't get my workout this
morning so if you look at okay if you
look at the type strain for Pseudomonas
or any path of our API it's quite a bit
different than those BS strains which is
all salinas as opposed to other BS quite
a bit different than those other BS
strains up there and so there's there's
been a change in what we're I sell eree
and from now parsley so parsley strains
Pseudomonas syringae path of our API but
they're also Pseudomonas syringae path
of our coriander cola in the Pseudomonas
can of beaten group so here's a place
where we actually have two different
organisms causing the same disease on
parsley okay and I can tell you that in
you can make the Pseudomonas syringae
path of our coriander cola
you can make that pathogen a pathogen on
celery you can inoculate it you can get
some kind of plant reaction but you you
we've never seen it from the field on
celery and likewise we can get a plant
reaction from Pseudomonas or any path of
our API
on coriander or cilantro but in fact we
never see it from the field
okay so there's a difference between
what we're seeing in the fields and what
is actually causing disease and what we
isolate or what we can get to cause
disease or plant reactions in the
greenhouse so what does this mean to a
grower so in the Salinas Valley where
the the land is rented for two thousand
to three thousand dollars an acre per
year it's really expensive land that's
just the rent they turn over crops
really quickly and in fact if somebody
is a celery grower they might grow some
of these other crops but they're not
going to be growing lettuce or they may
not grow some other kinds of crops they
usually stick with in the same plant
family so if somebody's growing parsley
and they have the disease we really
recommend they rotate out of the ABAC
completely but if they're growing celery
and they get the disease they could go
and and plant cilantro so there's
there's a crop rotation system that they
can use that they won't see the pathogen
again that's one option okay so this is
the kind of strategy we use once we know
what the organisms are and what the host
ranges are and what we're seeing from
the field this is what I consider
translational taxonomy okay it's
everybody with me every some people are
going on oh maybe that'll work okay I
want to tell you another story this is
the story of peppers spot of cruciferous
and I want to tell that primarily
because I know people are working on
Pseudomonas touring epatha bar macula
Kola and organisms like that here so
this is the pepper spot this is some
symptoms of pepper spot on this I just
I'll just tell you that McCulloch was a
plant pathologist at the USDA at the
same time that say or when F Smith was
the leader of the program there and you
notice that that publication is
McCulloch 1911 at that time women were
allowed to publish without their
supervisors on the publication's so
Erwin F Smith who was considered the
father of phyto bacteriology
I had a number of women that worked for
him that published independently and did
independent research and I think it's an
interesting historical fact that that
that happened during the 1920s or early
early 1900s and then like 30 years later
during the 50s
I guess that's 40 years later I can't
count anyway you know later women were
not allowed to publish and in fact often
women did a lot of the work and were not
even included on the publication's and
so I think that's a very interesting
historical fact nonetheless she isolated
pseudomonas macula coli it was called
something else when she isolated it and
many many people work with Pseudomonas
syringae path of our macula Kola but in
fact they're working with Pseudomonas
canopy in a path about half of our Alice
lenses this is an organism that has been
studied for a number of years and I just
want to show you a little bit about how
we determined that this really was a kin
Adina but the host range for this
organism is different than the
Pseudomonas arena path of our macula
kolja host range in that it is a
pathogen of monocots and there are a
number of crops that will see the
pathogen on that we don't see
Pseudomonas syringae path of our macula
Galan when we first saw this organism
causing blight on arugula or on broccoli
raab we thought it was Pseudomonas
stirring a path of our macula Club
because it was coming off of a crucifer
and it was a Pseudomonas syringae okay
so one of the organisms that's worked
with you know as a model for Pseudomonas
syringae capibara macula Kola is es for
3 to 6 and I think people here work on
it right anybody ever see that number
before it's a great organism it causes
devastating disease on radish and it I
know it's a great organism it kills
things okay the thing is that there
there have been comparisons between this
organism - Pseudomonas or any path of
our tomato and there have been
explanations of you know molecular
explanations by why there are different
paths of ours or wide different
maybe different races or things like
this but there are actually different
species and so our thoughts about what
this organism is doing and what the
molecules that were analyzing are doing
have to be broadened to to realize we're
looking at two different species okay
and I know that's kind of somebody's
shocking so again this this was the
different genomic here's Janome especie
x' 9 so this is es 4 3 2 6 and an MLS a
and it is identical to the path no type
there's a paper where we actually look
at the whole genome sequences of these
organisms and there are some difference
when differences when we look at ret PCR
and the host range so when we isolate
from arugula and radish we only see the
es 4 3 2 6 type which is this organism
here now other other plants we can
isolate and we'll see Pseudomonas or any
path of our ala salensus the path of
type type so there's an interesting
difference there that yes you can
inoculate those plants and get disease
but really in the field what we're
seeing is only one type or the other
depending upon the host range okay but
both of these go to both crucifer and
monocots
and that is a really exciting place that
people are working as well I should say
that you can see there's path of our
philadelphi and then the coriander here
I have a student Beth Alger who is now
at Michigan State who were working on a
paper to go ahead and change the
nomenclature of all of those as well
because we know that you love when we
change the names of organisms okay um
and I'm sorry I don't know when the
seminar ends so what is the time 105
okay we're gonna forget the cute curb at
one I just got talking let me talk a
little bit about mushrooms so we're
using the same kind of technique to to
look at mushroom diseases and so this is
bacterial blotch in mushrooms there have
been attempts to control this disease
using bacteriophage and I've worked with
bacteriophage and a number of different
systems and what's interesting about it
is that in a mushroom production house
you really have a contained system so
when I think about biological control
that seems like a natural place to be
able to deploy biological control the
problem is we know from the literature
that there are a number of different
organisms that's how we do pathogenicity
testing on mushroom tissue there are a
number of different organisms keep going
that cause the diseases on mushrooms and
so blotch can be caused by Pseudomonas
to lass I which is what is the
traditionally thought of as a blotch
organism but there's also Pseudomonas
ginger I which is up here and then a
number of other organisms have been
shown to cause the disease so we wanted
to know what's causing disease in
mushrooms in Pennsylvania so what we did
was survey we've surveyed so far seven
different mushroom houses and this shows
you the sampling array from two beds of
mushrooms that we looked at in one house
and for each of these circles if there's
two colors that means on one cap we
isolated from two different spots and
got two different species from that same
spot each color represents a different
species this one had three different
species on that cap so there are a
number of species we think at least
seven species of the path of pathogens
causing blotch on mushrooms so when
someone came the researchers in the past
had looked at using bacteria faj to
control this disease they had a
bacteriophage that was effective against
one organism but there are more than one
organism there and so we're actually
working with a class to isolate
bacteriophage to all of these different
pathogens so that we can try using a
cocktail of them and and as we monitor
what organisms are present in houses in
different houses and I'll just move
forward we're using a similar approach
for black blackleg and soft rot of a
potato and I know so
you know that there's a Dickey added dam
the cola is now and has been detected in
the north northeast and of course across
the US and so I have a new student
Amanda Minh yellow who is working on
this and she's really interested in
looking at a microbiome approach to
doing this okay I'm gonna skip through
that and just tell you that Emma
Rosenthal who was in Gregg Martin's lab
is currently working on a one of my
favorite projects which is a lettuce
disease problem this is bacterial leaf
spot on lettuce that she works on and
she we have already characterized both
the the diversity of the organisms that
cause the disease but we also know that
there are three races of the organisms
that cause the disease and we have
differential hosts for that we know that
at least for one of them there's a
single gene for resistance so Emma is
working currently we're working on
classifying these organisms because
they're not suits santhu Mona's
competitors they're really Xanthomonas
or tourim there's another name change
sorry and she's done she's done a great
job she's actually sequence 27 strains
and has assembled those for whole genome
analysis to to really understand what
these differences are and what what are
the factors that are related to the race
relationships she will be using forward
and reverse genetics to do that so that
just gives you an idea of what we're
working on now with that particular
group okay if I have a few seconds I
just want to say something about the
department this is who we are as a group
we're currently 26 faculty we run
usually around 25 to 26 graduate
students although we've been asked to
push that up to 40 by our Dean and so
that's an interesting thing everybody is
going how many graduate students do I
need to have yeah and so that's a kind
of interesting goal and we have some
strategies to get there but that's who
we are as a group we have four different
signature areas that we concentrate on
and within each signature area we
actually have Ford
different areas that that we techniques
or strategies for researching these
areas if you will so whether we're in
mushroom science and technology we use
these three different or four different
emphases to look at that area and so
that'll give you kind of a summary of
who we are research wise we have a new
strengths and Fido biomes we've hired
two people in particular but we're part
of a larger group and that's what this
is so a year ago well yeah a year ago we
started the microbiome Research Center
and we currently have 100 scientists who
are involved in this we have ten that
are part of a cluster higher five that
were hired in medicine five that were
hired in agriculture and there are about
five more that will be coming on board
three and AG so the the College of Ag
has made a huge investment in this area
and they asked me if I would lead the
center primarily because they wanted to
have a really strong foundation for the
faculty that they're bringing in to be
able to collaborate together and they're
doing a great job I'd love to talk to
anyone about how we've organized this
Center but we we have a lot of
interaction even with the arts for
example we're having a symposium in the
next in November we have two different
sessions that we'll be having at our
weekly meetings that are about arts and
microbiomes in ways that I never like
it's really good I'm not controlling it
because I would have never thought to do
what they're doing so we have a
documentarian who is very interested in
micro biomes and what that person is
doing is very different than planned
pathologist would would have a
documentarian do quite frankly and so
that's kind of exciting to me but would
across the board there's a lot of
different kinds of interactions
including with our social scientists
I'll just say that we have a lot of
different and initiatives within the
department that comes with having a new
department head the microbiome Center is
key to our strengthening our
environmental microbiology
emphasis but we have strengths in stem
and stem and access to stem and
diversity we're building a couple of
bilateral programs with international
institutes the primary one is with the
university of pretoria and that's been
very successful and we have had gotten a
lot out of that we the workshop that we
had today is part of our comprehensive
professional professionalism train
training and one of the things that I've
gotten a lot of pleasure in is really
engaging with the alumni in the industry
so I think that's it Oh last thing is
just to advertise the degrees we have I
think two things that are unique about
our program is we have dual titles with
plant pathology so our students walk out
the door with a PhD in plant pathology
and maybe a PhD in biochemistry or plant
pathology and international AG and
development we also have an online
certificate and add biosecurity and food
defense and we have a couple of minors
we don't have a major in plant pathology
for the undergraduates but we have
minors which feed our programs feed your
programs in fact and feed other people's
programs and so more the merrier and
there we go
my acknowledgments and I want to thank
you all for your patience and listening
to some of the things we do in my lab ok
any questions
[Applause]
who's on zoom' who's on first I don't
hear anything okay and I've run right up
to the limit that's what happens when so
I have to say I planned this chalk last
night I decided I decided that I wanted
to do something different than I've done
before and so this is my first time
trying to talk about these things in
this way and so I'll try it again next
time maybe it'll be shorter it was
curious you gave a really elegant
example of the deciphering baton some of
the the entities associated
Diseases parsley but that kind of a
detailed knowledge and study won't be
often available or the Resources Board
so presumably you have a vision of
tiered management strategy where you
lose your management recommendations
instead of your understanding biology
absolutely yeah so so for example often
before I would even begin a research
project what I would ask the what I ask
growers is what are your options how are
you going to manage this what are the
things you are likely to do and once I
get those answers then I can actually
target this study if if if they know
it's a pseudo if they know it's
bacterial and they only have two options
for control that's all we need to know
is it bacterial is it not right and so
it really depends what options are
available to the growers so with the
mushroom growers they're very innovative
they have they have some extra money so
they would be willing to invest in
products they would be willing to invest
in development of products and so
looking at for example these development
of a bio control for them makes sense
okay because that that high-value cash
crop would make sense that wouldn't
necessarily make sense for lettuce okay
and so my first question is always to
the producers what kinds of things do
you have money for what kinds of things
are you willing to do does that make
sense is that answer your question
totally we don't have any mushrooms
produced in New York but sort of options
to Pennsylvania mushroom growers have
four control or reduction of bacterial
diseases
it's such a fun crop oh my goodness i
when I moved to Pennsylvania I thought
how lucky could a pseudomonas girl be
right that you've got all these and an X
pseudomonas is involved in the
stimulation of mushroom growth so the
actual fruiting body formation by the
fungus is stimulated by Pseudomonas
Pewter like organisms so that's a whole
nother ball of wax right you don't want
to kill off the good guys and you want
to kill off the bad guys and so so one
of the things that that conventional
growers can use is chlorine II organic
growers cannot use chlorine okay for
example the the primary methods for
control are sanitation steam so they
steam their whole rooms they can steam
the entire room and humidity control but
that isn't optimal for like the the
things that are optimal for pathogen
control are not optimal for growth and
so they're constantly doing this fine
balance and in the organic systems they
really tip toward disease often and so
in fact we were just awarded a million
dollar ory grant so that's the organic
research extension initiative funding to
work on this and a couple of other
diseases in relationship to biological
control in particular and microbiome
analysis more generally so they really
have humidity control sanitation and
chlorine and then if you take away
chlorine for the organic folks its
sanitation and humidity control and so
they're really looking for other options
and I think you know they're already
starting to get a picture that that
their disease problems are more
complicated than they once thought right
so that really is my job is to let
people know that their disease problems
are more complicated than they thought
and they can't just deal with one
breeder they need to work with us to
curious how all this flux in taxonomy
how that is intersected with
international trade barriers of
regulatory sort of things are they
keeping up with the changes or are they
yes
not at all yeah in fact I have been
working with a fasciculus
just the permitting section to try to
get them up-to-date and the
understanding of what the bacterial
taxonomy is because some of them really
do understand it and as they bring new
people in you know we want to make sure
that they're up to date as well so I
would have to look at my calendar but I
believe there's a visit to a facade my
calendar soon to give the whole two or
three hour version of bacterial taxonomy
at a glance yeah I the the folks from
the pense the Penn State Department of
Agriculture can't ask me to come and
talk about bacterial taxonomy and I said
to them well I feel like I've done an
adequate job when I've talked for a week
how long can I have right and so I know
a week of bacterial taxonomy I always
try to make it fun and so I've had a
number of people come visit me for a
week so that they can do it other
questions so now you know what
translational taxonomy is perhaps this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu